just remember to use our magic twice one
goes through these issues raised and
then happy occasion so they wanted
forcing discuss we might be might bring
your windowsill commerce how long have
you known or somewhat have me hopping
through them you know these are all
personal it's whether annoyed with its
to detail for the document the veneks
how we then divisional as an author
notation negative net local investor
June
yeah one of these Black Knight systems
where you try and transmitted is found
the design two sides into tables
efficiency make a lot of good but we
don't have a go good will be pretty good
mind you so they built bad exactly they
have approval for you to have had been
in this army wasn't really still they
depart and you will see there's a really
colorful I had imagined debilitation
we're having four extra members am here
I've been nice salmon possibly are now
in the building that I linked up to the
patio
flattened to play through passing out of
the air chambers estimates got very loud
and clear maybe a little picking up the
other ideas plans tomorrow people
calling in to take the there mal just
not even there that equality be exactly
cuz don't we can well the only in the
gear with Adam and offered before cool
don't know much about the most imprison
what time were announced it to the whole
thing with you now we're down to the
realm are primarily now things are
points a lot of climbers it looks so big
one to four thousand feet then I could
work if we work on their FB i--'s John
Cena for yourself Jesse this is that
short yellow starting
ladies and gentlemen everybody W are
anticipating be here is here so if
you're quite happy will make the start
in comes along the side of the
undeserving so he can bring them up to
speed as well necessary before we start
the usual routine emergency evacuation
procedure in the event of a fire or
other emergency please are killed in an
orderly manner the assembly point where
you located in the marking car passed
the fire exits this room is indicated by
the green fire exit sign please do not
be like the evacuation by flexing any
lines do not use the lid the process
must not be entered reinterred until the
fire brigade have given the all-clear
there is no
smoking these browsers is this me being
all the area for you please note this
meeting will be all the other equally
thank you apologies for evidence on you
counselor you are new is being
substituted by castle from counselor
black has been substituted by cancer
stan lee and in car services use okay
thank you and we have no non-members
attendee you do we sorry counselor war
sorry sorry n minutes of the meeting of
the locally Berman framework
subcommittee held only them for februari
this was subsequently passed to full
council and approved linings on the
twenty-third battle on memory and make
better for me to make on that anybody
thank you to receive any declarations of
interest no
terms of reference is there anything to
to elaborate on there at that point they
just for noticing the other team thank
you very much right moving on to item 6
Christine if you would like to take the
lead on this in his shoe show young lads
is usually the penny policy obviously
with the the growth that we got from the
budget for this year and next year it
allowed us to look at some additional
resources in the team and this resulted
in the team on two young fellows then a
Goodman and zagging Creston they're both
on fixed one-year contracts and so
they'll be with us for a year and made
me roll onto a second year what their
job is to do is to pick up a lot of the
evidence base work that we've had to
paint other consultants for so their new
very very I would say very experienced
in terms of their their knowledge base
from their degree courses in terms of
what we want from them and their scarily
good which makes me feel very old it so
basically and they've been working on
the same community involvement in terms
of the consultation responses and also
daniel and dan has been working on a lot
of the engagement that we've done so far
in terms of parish council engagement so
he's very much involved in the
composition in terms of consultation and
between Dan and Zakia they've actually
then looked at before we have done over
the past six months and in spite of
seven and actually looking at what we're
giving going to be doing it in the next
few months so our plans are to take as
read both reports but I think in terms
of looking at the state and community
involvement I think what what Custis
bearings it's pretty quite good is the
fact that
unless you've got anything else you want
to discuss is the fact we just go
through the comments in terms of the
issues raised by people that work thank
goodness responded to the constellation
it's all of a sudden econ session where
no one responds to it and then just look
at the comments that we've made from an
officer's point of view if you look back
in the document it does set out at Table
three they've proposed modifications
that we move undertaken to that document
to meet any requirements to chain the
document to meet any of the suggestions
bearing in mind that you have to be
careful this is this runs as two things
it's not a this is basically how we come
consult it's not anything further any
foot further in policymaking will be
dealt with in the local plan itself and
you have to do you have to almost
divorce the local plan from this this is
actually just a method of consultation
it's nothing more than that so if you
want to go through and both down inside
you have done so any questions you've
got so
which is something he can we can we just
take it just we were start working
through this systematically can we are
there any issues to anybody or you want
to elaborate eating bangs or up to table
number three because i think you know
we've gone through all the other bits
and pieces to the fingers and all the
rest room where it was done it set for
excessive how we did it and does anybody
have any comments regarding before that
or after table 3 with the amendments
that are being proposed to be included
for the future reference if dropped on
just one question every team raised this
and returning George on the last
occasion and I suppose I'm going to be
asking what is there any evidence from
this first part of the presentation that
we managed to get to hard to reach
people
do and what I can say from from the
perspective of actually doing the admin
on the comments that I mean I noticed
that there was quite broad range of
respondents and I mean we have detailed
the kind of methods we use to consult
people said we got two people are
mailing this which would obviously be
people who have contacted the planning
policy team before and show an interest
and I believe we also put things on our
website and we also made believe
advertisement so i'd like i'd like to
say that we did put as much exposure for
this consultation out there as we
reasonably could and i'd like to I'd
like to think that that includes harder
to reach me as well as perhaps
traditional respondents unfamiliar be
good so we did also attend then which
was no mention we did also attend the
events as described as discussed about
that meeting and that's that out
engagement events we weren't we were at
the the Iranian roxford district
voluntary pushing laundry service event
on 24th of march so we did attend that
so hopefully we did actually attempt to
to do with people and also the kind work
that all the parishes and the town
councils did in terms of allowing that
off that that advert to go into all
those parish or all the pouch and papers
and letters so in terms of reaching the
carriages themselves and the town
councils that would have reached
everybody who actually read that so even
though we can't say definitely everybody
in that part of each bit we've got it we
can guarantee that in a proportion that
wouldn't actually have some some some
way of knowing it exactly what
you can't put up a couple I'm not sure I
noticed in the the stats how many people
would have used their Janie I consulting
software as well as online and how many
people would have used other means to
communicate everybody pray on that down
and I don't believe we've noted in this
pub enough heat up yeah while I see you
down there were 53 responding switch
made off with little welcoming and I
don't have the number of burn with me
but i would say that a good number
probably in the region of 35 of those
respondents came through jdi and some
came by letter we had quite a few
letters from men's of the whole British
Community Association don't typically
came through by letter but the majority
and definitely came free by JD I and
that number should be pretty he's coming
to get you would like him yeah I've got
the impression in the past that people
have bigger felt
I don't know they felt it difficult to
to tackle the JDL approach and I know
that we're going to encourage I'm asleep
them to come through other channels are
the media I seem to remember you
mentioned hullbridge I i would also
mention hotly from the perspective out
of their previous consultations and
there was a stream of people who are
sending you paint 0 comments and we
found it incredibly difficult to
actually deal with them in fact at one
point you couldn't actually see looking
at the all of the website comments in
other words to get as members or anybody
else engaged what was happening it was
some weeks before that managed to catch
up and it was kept caught up a long time
after it closed so I I'm asking the
question from the point of views what
was the proportion and how do we deal
with it sounds like it wasn't a problem
and I guess my next question is to say
at what point will it come a problem and
how will you deal with it because we're
going to deal with it better than we did
last time
you I think I mean in terms of the in
terms of the systems that we've got in
place the moment I would say if we were
going for the issues option document
which really the first people that go
out conversational we go consultation
important this year if we were doing
that now I would have serious concerns
loading that the information onto the
system of that bowl look at Chelmsford
and then he is at 14,000 respondents
they had to their issues of options
document so i would say today if we did
it say I would have serious concerns the
speed of uploading looking at the fact
that we will be in a different position
with the ICT in by the autumn I would
say that I have less concerns by that
point and it's with with staff embedded
now in the team and by age point down
and up here with a raincoat and we'll
have knowledge of the systems the
ability to upload things straight away
is what's key and I think what happened
historically with local plans is the
fact that the documents were uploaded
and later in the process whereas now our
opposition with without even for the
taking it was walking away from this in
terms of information will be uploaded as
it as it arrives in the council so it we
scanned and source are the aims would be
the fact that the post would come in
that on till today if we scanned into
the system and it will be uploaded
straight away that there should be no
like time if you might find the lifetime
it may be 24 hours but they won't be a
massive like a time what won't be done
with the information and that's what I
think is the next step is it's an
analysis of that information so we will
have a clear log of what's come in its
then how that is then sorted is the next
thing so everything will be available to
view online so very quickly analysis and
sorting and would be the next step and
that might take a bit longer but why
would probably say is about that
autumn you'll be able to go online and
view in consultation period what
response we've had to that document what
will then have to do with that
information is then sort it out and put
into order that may take a bit more for
but it will be available and it'll be
standard source tell having carriage
back cool but perhaps John you know we
could put in in in the minutes that you
raised this issue I mean in kristen has
given us an answer that we believe he's
going to meet our requirements as
technique art that we would we hire like
this and we will express our concern
that if this isn't going to be made that
we are made aware of it as soon as it
clears up as a potential problem and
down jokin there's no this document
deals with the engagement yeah what the
next step is is how we then does it
again yeah look at that engagement and
how we then put it into a format which
we then use and that isn't what this
docking wasn't going to that in that day
to this this is actually how we reach
out there the next step is actually
internally how we then deal with
information so we can actually make it
available is that the consultation can't
just be it has to be externalized
otherwise it's got no value I understand
where I understand that I was just
trying to understand but this was a
consultation regardless about whether it
was all the core strategy provision
itself which it wasn't if but
nevertheless it was a way for us to look
at you know how consultation is taking
place on whether we're happy we with the
process the other question I might've
don't look
at the online progress if you like I
didn't you know sit there and start
ticking how many people responded to
what sections I must have been the first
four weeks I didn't see many are talking
and in particular those that were there
from hull breach residents association
who completely organized than an
activity and a lot of residents
associations to do that with enable pass
I'm thinking that if we were able to
monitor the progress of the engagement
in terms of numbers of people coming to
the consultation if we are if we are
having a flexible consultation
communication process which is exactly
what we're doing here then we might
consider I don't know finding some way
of promoting it in other words if we're
not getting a great response you know as
you would do in a commercial situation
you you would be spending a lot of money
and you want to get that response so you
want to design methods into your
progress to say hey we've only had 50
people hey we've only had you know so
many by Dayton I mean we need to find
ways of thing getting I don't think I
think you would be you're crossing an
area between what is required by the
council to do and what we would have
done a commercial world I think you got
we haven't obviously have a budget we
have a need to do a consultation and we
have certain requirements that we have
to mean yep
and I accept what you're saying join but
we can't force people to be splits on a
same thing is a case of you know
basically putting it up here ten people
by but by the best methods product at
the beginning I'm suggesting that we
need repeater through the process think
otherwise we're not forcing people so we
need to remote that engagement because
my perception was perception okay my
perception was we wrote in the beginning
but we didn't I didn't see much repeater
work artis yeah I think also the work
we're doing and the windage withstands
aveo knuckle you're doing parishes and
the town councils but only that early
collaborative what they're doing and if
we've done two so far and I mean sat out
in the project work no long that only
work with with the parish with the
parishes of the perigee not just past
projects parishes is actually a way of
telling people what's going on is
actually is that we've we've engaged
with with two so far under the
engagement be across the whole district
by in the summer and then what will
happen is after that is once we get
dishes an option stage we're going to be
going back to the parish the same the
same parishes again in the evening to
run an evening session with the parishes
again to say following on from the
collaborative approach we had in the
first case we produced issues and
options document here is let's have a
look at how it affects you put your
parish and let's have a discussion about
that and then hopefully like you say
that might make people want to respond
to that document at the end of that
that session and that's actually trying
to promote an early collaborative
approach rather than have this the the
state when we get to is where you get
the allocations and the final look of
man going out and then we get all the
masses responses to that we'd rather
have 14,000 responses issues and options
document and only 5,000 to the local
plan rather than have no correspondence
issues an option stage and all later
down the line because issues and options
as not all lower faculties do them the
ones that do them are showing their
having a massive spike in consultation
and a lot of the problems are are ironed
out by the time you get to policymaking
and anti location both commercial and
residential this is not just about how
this is about the Sochi kilometers of
the district which is I think it's more
important than housing itself so I think
that it's that only engagement which
we're doing the moment make people aware
and that's physical physically talking
to people not actually just sending the
letters around and that engagement is
really important and I think that
actually is showing that that engagement
face-to-face German that's a different
question I want to come to that later
when we talk about the second paper I
think it's best to do that okay well I'm
what I'm actually read doings aren't
recommending that during the process of
any consultation that we we measured the
response rate or not we wanna really
intervento basis and design our
engagement process to respond to that we
buy a to correct yeah that's what I
recommend question it I just like to
comment on
like John said because what what we're
actually saying i think is we're not
necessarily reaching any more people
which was the whole name of this so we
get more responses it's good to hear
13,000 responses to Chancellor but you
know the console of the day we'll look
at anything like that we get 50 52 what
was anything enhanced communication
strategy to go out to all places early
engagement is one thing but if it's
mainly with the parishes from here on
that's an assumption that the parishes
are then also going to disseminate that
information in a meaningful way that's
going to get to reach most are here all
it is a lot lot of parishes we're doing
with dr. parish council the team of the
toe shoes there were same difference as
far as I'm concerned anything that is
organized within a parish only attracts
is that a number of people and generally
the same people and I think where John's
coming from the issue that George John
and I were concerned that previously was
we're only reaching a certain number of
people with whatever we go out to
consultation with yes I understand what
you're saying about the statutory
requirements and we meet that but for us
it's about reaching the people somehow
better and i'm not actually convinced
that we've done that given the responses
that we've got to this albeit a
consultation on a consultation process
so for me I'm not actually clear that we
we've got a lot written about who we
communicated with but it hasn't bought a
better rate a response which is I think
what we were hoping he would do but he's
is there because the people that
happened they may have read Ian chose
not to make any comment I don't think
that was the case because they were
happy with what they dress I suspect
it's because they have not accessed it
they may have read whatever has been
posted wherever that says this document
is available for you to respond to and
they thought all right okay and it does
now how do you how do you force
engagement I'm elastic is not about
place located how can you get them to
respond if it is jus said if they ready
and see it and I'll go right okay now
what but it's an awareness other nurse
of follow-up that says you know we need
your response and how you make that
attractive to make people want to
respond I don't know the answer to that
but that's really where where you're
coming from I think John as well isn't
it oh yes you do because once it's out
there and you just say rad we said we've
put it everywhere let's hope we get
thousands of responses well actually
we've got 55 all right good job I think
it's making engagement for this time
document I don't it isn't that this is
about this is a policy document this is
that this isn't actually there in terms
of in terms of engagement I think 55
responses he's actually
a good response listen no this just
shows an interest in what this document
is doing if this was issues an optimist
document and we had to 55 responses to
it I'd be worried but a document of this
of this nature basically it's it's it's
pretty people aren't interested in in
this type of document that what they'd
be interested in is the next documents
and that's why what we should be trying
to deliver through this is that is that
engagement rasta G that make sure that
we can we know we know who to contact
now we've done we've done in terms of
this document we've done what we can to
put it out in the general public but in
terms of that the document is you know
looking at other men thorities that have
and when talking first Adam this is have
been done all over the country there is
a very low respond response rate
document it's not a document that
produces lots of responses so I don't
think as an authority we should be we
should be concerned that you haven't had
responses to it because that is just the
nature of this document it's a statement
unit involvement people generally are
not interested we have we have done what
we have to do in terms of putting it out
there we've got lots of discussions and
we've tweaked it in our our decisions in
here to make sure it meets that it meets
our needs as accounts in terms of our
involvement going forward and what I
think we need to make sure it's about
that that involvement is is a mixed
level of involvement across all
different age groups different needs and
different levels of activity to ensure
we get the correct evolvable to stop it
sets out so in real terms what I my
point of view is in fact that
the issues options document on their own
would be one being at your high volume
these responses from anyone get high on
responses from that this document is no
different than every other local
authorities they were pointing all week
if you look across the country so you
know it's they are all they are all thus
they are all documents on the same time
so if we're having problems and you're
concerned about our engagement then it's
the same problems for every single and
authority across the country in terms of
them I thought this plan making this
this document does with every engagement
of the planning process not just plan
making so that's the issue is the fact
that if what if what your if what you're
concerned about here my point is the
fact that if this is the same document
that is used representing potato moment
this is in that Chris coming for us
because he and then so gum bizarre I was
trying to a great Jonah that as for the
public boys I don't think there's been
enough i think i've been at the over
year now the boys and i don't i don't
remember seeing documentation leaving
like this just has come forward at raw
if i don't know what parish councils
you'll be dealing with in law what we've
just seen but I've not seen anything on
the table droid parish council so I'm a
bit
talk about this in as much as happen I
hadn't seen so and i'm sure that
understood or how you would have given
us this in black and white so I've not
seen anything in black and white in my
plea on from before on the crutches you
know my head I will ask the question we
only have a monthly meeting so i will
bring an issue now you to go to issue
it's not because I'm substitute for
cohere eurozone i obviously on doc I'm
in the dark berry but as far as on up
chris hasn't mentioned it to us at the
monthly meeting and this is all probably
we all knew ago the consultation i think
i think chris is right i mean if i
hadn't been a member discount ala nabina
we're basically because i was looking
for it and i think people who are aware
of it and perhaps will respond or not
our concerns mentioned how wish
Residents Association and that's just
sort of thing they will be looking for
there for
they've received having seen it whether
they respond it's very much up to them
is very similar to elections you've got
a lengthy election since they fight
except for germination give a 65-percent
turn out if you have a referendum a
final tomorrow yeah but that that's it I
don't think even for think we're going
further if they don't want to respond on
interested in responding i don't think
it's worth responding I'm really
confident we can do much more you can
you can say you know your your opinions
do count we will take notice of them
that they won't believe it if they don't
want to believe it it's the same as that
human nature don't you want to finish
often because we what I do know whose it
was and we have to throw this back to to
you guys for August disease will because
I was trying to do chairman was was was
to simply you know up our game based on
on an observation you know that that I
had my and placed on some experience the
fact that how the council's even know
more successful than us all we have been
no more successful than their presbytery
rounded you ask the chicken is no reason
not to try to do better next time
because you recognize something that
really quickly improved to ensure that
you have a dynamic process going through
responding to the level of engagement I
think is appropriate and that's what I
recommended on a positive sense it
wasn't intended to go around in circles
it was intended to me I think we can do
better regardless of the dynamics of
this particular type of possible
the other point I want to be cover and I
don't want to cut back on this when we
talk about the Paris engagements later
is thicker what cancer London saying is
if I understood you correctly to is to
say that Paris is engage in a particular
way with their parishioners if you like
and the way they do it certainly doesn't
engage with everyone in the parish
boundary it just doesn't I've had lots
of experience as being a parish council
in two separate parishes and it goes
back over nearly 30 years I I am
concerned if we found basis of
engagement is reliant upon the people
that are engaged by parishes they only
engage a very small part of the
population and if we rely on that
nothing has to the gym the same then I
have concerns and I would wish to ensure
that when we do get to it rather
consultation on issues and options that
we're not just leveraging it through the
parishes because that will not be enough
okay let's play this back to the last
meeting we might I do so as long as you
want but there but we tried to highlight
air
well we felt there we would approach
ultimately what attachment screws I
think you've heard me off that while the
Christine and your team have done
exactly what we asked them to do
actually he hasn't worked quite as well
as we hoped the number of people have
been engaged and responded have had not
supported what we hoped would happen
although Christine quite right people
are so quite rightly I've no reason to
doubt your comments about the level of
responses is pretty good but perhaps you
can review other areas of or otherwise
and if you have any questions about how
you think we can improve engagement
across the district with any parties
there will be parishes whatever we need
to have another meeting to throw these
ideas around but then we're glad they
have one but we I know Christine you're
sober we metal out of legal affairs any
other areas because we don't want to go
down the road look we went pinned down
in the past with what we know you can
have more housing we know we're gonna
have more planning applications but we
want to try and make sure that everybody
as we start going down the road of some
of these issues that as many people are
in the system so to speak sort of a
better phrase and can be consulted Lee
and can be made aware of what's going on
before we get to all the atoms on
other areas of not very pleasant
situations there would be no no excuse
for not knowing what was going on this
cloudy a point with regards to the and
engaging we've done so far that have
been in the parachute this wallpaper and
it all by the parishes they those events
have involved so far in two parishes of
the small p then through the parish
councils we have organized those events
in collaboration with residents in those
areas and the parish council have been
invited to be part of that it's a
collaborative approach between the
residents in those areas the businesses
stakeholders the schools the model
engine we had the rspb there so it's not
a non-event run or operated by the
parishes an event that's run and
operated by and we facilitate it but our
aims and what we had with both laundries
and so far have been a mixture of people
have attended those meetings and they
would be really good and the impact
we've got from those has been quite
impressive in terms of the discussions
and the ability to actually then drill
down into further options for opening up
for the consultation with local schools
and also with with other loads of groups
that we won't probably got to so
actually I think that those actually at
that actual proches actually widened our
scope in terms of dealing with the
paratroopers more p because we've chosen
parish boundaries but it's easier to
deal with areas of high parish
boundaries and it is by looking at
larger areas so that that engagement has
been on a collaborative approach so that
we can start talking to residents that
live in the district and they're in an
environment which they know about which
okay in my terms is a concern because
it's still very introverted because we
don't look at this strategic
computing look at her but it gives
residents about residents businesses
stakeholders the schools and all a
chance to make comment and to open our
eyes to what we might not be smart see
and actually what it's open our eyes up
to is the fact that the residents all
understand there is a need for change or
understand that the processes that we're
going to go down into the community
involvement of it are key to this the
challenge we've had to it so far and the
one times we have had to it is why is it
taking place during the day and why is
it not taking place during the evening
that's the wrong turns we have had which
is why that though we revisit issues an
option stage back to that to those
groups back to that to those individual
parishes to open up discussions of the
similar sort around the issues and
options document once that's finalized
so actually we'll go we'll do a term
visit do an evening session but it's
also a short session to involve them to
everybody that isn't available to make
the earlier discussions and the session
starts off with a walk around the area
so it's not about actually you know what
to the Parish Council what actually
we've both with pennilyn and with with
Rochford we've wandered around those
areas and they said to us you know we
had them I had the village hall people
were there saying well we want any
village hall how can we do that then we
looked option to the village hall we've
walked around the school obsession with
us that this the school how's the school
run aground the long run society were
there just about rap about the
allotments so actually it's step outside
and having of course going on and I
think that actually is really important
that we start to understand what makes
the district tick what what the needs
are knud ins raised a concern because
Cleveland school's failing in terms of
the number numbers wise this issue that
that that's key to us in terms of
collusion and you had to have never
listened to all the residents about
their concerns about what some to their
school and
I think those are things that we know
you've they understand any growth
tonight the school to me to be retained
so mean that's all correspondence which
I think we would have missed out on if
we haven't actually gone back tues or
black two real roots planning and
actually gone out and spoken to people
so I don't think for my point of view
the committee involvement is key at that
stage because that is really proper
proper proper collaborative consultation
where actually listen to all sides oh we
we've now gone on to the area that I
wanted reserve till later photopin I
really gonna have to raise it now
because you know it immutably fits in
what was always much look I I'm aware of
the parish engagement program from Paris
engagement program which is actually set
out in the second paper but equally I
have been been following what's been
happening and the engagement must be
surely unless you tell me otherwise with
a very limited number of people from a
very limited catchment who put
themselves forward to attend workshops
and walk around the news etc what I'm
concerned about in the larger parishes
they may work in small kanoon can see
how in could work in notch in town that
I can't see how it works across the
whole of the two rows awards for
instance hi I'm in football for instance
and put bears down
to be confirmed or September we're
talking about an inhabitant number of
something like 11,000 people now if
we're going to engage with significantly
a materially with the parishioners of
the whole core parish which is the two
big Ward's in the district to the large
schools in the district then engaging
with 25 people who've been drawn from a
very limited catchment of those who are
who look out four parishes but those who
participate in those sort of things if
that's going to inform what goes into
our issues and options document that I
fear that won't be representative now
that in itself is fine but I may find my
sellers of all counselor looking at a
very limited subset of people who who I
represent and I then got to go out again
myself at my expense to engage them
properly in the process so I'm concerned
not with the fact that we've tried to be
innovative but how we're going to use it
if we're going to use that to inform our
issues and options I think that there is
a very real risk that will be so narrow
too narrow to be able to draw
conclusions for that and therefore we
may get we will get a large response
because in all honesty if if I'm not
happy as a member and other world
members are member the street in a real
reward
how are happy then they'll want to
re-engage with the wider population that
this hasn't actually connect with
morning or evening it doesn't actually
more often doesn't really matter and
we'll end up with a very big response to
our issues and options probably so big
that we have to do it again having
framed it more appropriately sorry i've
gone on long yeah but Christine is my
given her view I'm given mind that how
illness and then in mind taking my lord
which is just down the road here an
awful lot of people aren't interested
sorry John and though not interest I've
talked to them Dave so my board as well
sorry there is not the interest though
that I don't care if I went and knocked
on every door assume people would not be
into your counselors you're there to
deal with it that's what we've elected
you for I'm sorry that's fantastic but I
don't have a problem where do we go do
we put a legal it through everybody's
door and say yes yes this is what we do
if that's what we want to do that he'll
we recommend that's what I have to just
be part this is this isn't I know I'm
not that naive to think that we go out
to it with little meeting are with a few
local parish local people and we we
draft mission options document from that
this is the whole idea of engagement
issue and as the council what we said is
that you engage in different ways with
different different people and you then
put it all together so actually and
we'll do some engagement with schools
and that is really really
gauging with the schools I think it's
actually you know you do lots of
different types of engagement and it all
produces a way to define lies that your
lobsters document you will not finalize
this use an option document based on on
us meeting with a certain number of
people in a parish and draft a document
from that that is not a that that goes
pop the information we get from this
will go to part of the way to looking at
that it is not your document it's not it
will no way be the the founding sort of
that document we've got a very strong
evidence base we've got a call for
science document we've been having
worked and taken on human development
we're having we've option of the shimano
we've got we've got lots of work around
retail been taking a moment all that is
what forms the evidence base for the
issues an option document what this is
this is that that the touch around the
edge that has a look at actually what is
that what are they what what do people
want to see and actually if we haven't
had any engagement we've got no idea and
there's no way that you can draft in
your adoption document we spoke to
people and they sent the following our
response back is this I mean the issues
not the document I'm producing protocol
and document in um a job stocking we
have its vision of option stage we had
105 responses to it so you know and we
did all sorts of engagement of all sorts
of levels so you know I thought I've you
know I'm used to doing engagement too
hard to reach people because that's
right of a new room when you is zero
response the fact that we've got hundred
nothing doesn't come out hundred five
responses for us was fantastic because
nuin does not respond so you know I
don't I've done more heart of each
community engagement than possibly in it
you'll ever do in English because we
were dealing with massive cultural
issues English top in the first language
a transient population we were doing
that we're drafting documents mainly
around housing
to look at those issues so i think that
the engagement has to be on various
levels to ensure that people who live in
the district how to say of what's going
on now this approach might do with a
small group of people those of it if way
of dealing with other groups of people
that we need to look at and quite right
in here the cats to me except that is
what you're going to do and i think that
you know that is the next step we're
looking at engagement the children we
can that that's going to be delivered in
the autumn we looked at looking at
second one second of school Felicia's
options document once active useful post
that we're looking at primary schools
for engagement as well because that also
if you engage children what they go home
and they go home and they tell their
parents and their parents get engaged
and we found that a lot of the Gator
week are they who came from the youth
council and came from children going
home to their parents and saying what
we've done today is so I think that
engagement world will look at it's
actually taking different types of game
which is what this says is different
types of engagement and with all that
information you then come to a 20 up to
a best way to engage do we I mean do we
come to a point here where we only
require dad's going to be here doing
this in the future
Sevilla up you know you've heard what
we've said do we have another meeting in
X number of months time before the
people we start progressing you take on
board what we've said and you know this
is what we recommend because we can't
solve the solution you know god Sophie
issues value your guys are going to be
here in producing some of this stuff and
you could have made aware of it you may
take it way things better so actually no
that's rubbish your web and these are
the reasons or whether or no that's a
good idea perhaps we can progress that
one but come back to us with with some
thoughts the oats with Christine user
experience and see where we go I mean I
don't think we're going to come to a
solution today on how we how we progress
with is but I mean if we only be so
people illegally in every door I know
we're not set up a go same as we do
without over their own literature a lot
of people just fine Dave like it i get a
far bigger response rate of that from my
ward but don't know how you were cause i
can honestly tell you I didn't do that
we think is gary's turn out in the
district in my ward actually talking
about elections are not here in about
four remember injection no but we do die
because we we will go down alpina join
me go happily glad we're going to a
different subject so i think i go
further
organised public meeting in a hall but
and leaflets for every drop urging more
to come you might get the properly
packed out but only a small handful
actually participating that the other
will go away from the wheezing at the
end of insane I've got meeting up or eps
a waste of time or whatever and you
still get the same small handful of
people who actually participating now
but there will be more people who will
have been involved first point but look
at that way that's what we've already
done but we don't know if they don't
want to be able to possess dave says you
can't fault them input I do the whole
point of what we've been saying I think
is that we're not convinced that i'm not
a large number of people have been
informed so far just because all of the
exercises that have been undertaken
because there has been small attendants
the small response but i think what you
wind up shall do through you Jim is to
get past this meaning with a lot of
people that they've already made other
plans anyway so whatever you say any
difference and that was a huge
difference
I don't profess it's an earlier I don't
want anything anyway I really don't want
to to witness as indeed none of us do
here and I'm sure everyone who are
members new members and older members
outside of this meeting we don't want to
see the situation that was claimed in
rayleigh those these these plans these
consultations didn't engage them and and
after the event when it was too late and
we said that when he was too late they
complained in their huge numbers that
they weren't engaged and I want to make
completely sure by non forcing methods
to ensure that I am completely satisfied
through every part of
that they were engaged whether they
chose to respond to that engagement was
another issue I mean you could even go
down the road of the only statistically
switch will be involving the counselors
with all the counselors in future blues
I'll just throw this one that you feel
the best thing to do was to put a notice
through every door and we can't afford
to deliver it
you give it to the moon countless knew I
wouldn't do that didn't know if I'm
acting as a ward councillor then I do
and I did last time I was left with the
responsibility in my ward you know I
took the view that I would run a
intensive engagement with individuals
there was a public meeting several
hundred people attended all that several
hundred there were that there was the
same number actually responded the
consultation now there wouldn't have
been the same number of people that
attended but it meant that that message
because of that public meeting got
through so if the leaflets and
everything else I'm not in a position
i'm not i'm not interested in doing the
council's corporate work for it i will
do it for my ward or do it gladly I'll
pay for it frankly I think they count
and I'll do it and the council should
pay for it I didn't say that i said if
you are concerned for the council if
there is an issue with GV m three if
we're talking about cost which is going
to be an issue the council can print
whatever they want to do if we wanted to
assist in this and ward councillors wish
to do this up to them or you ask the
council good but it would have to be put
into a budget and that's what will have
to be done well just go back to me what
this document is vote there's a
consultation process which the council
has got embedded into sorbus process is
already what this document has to do is
buy nor is set out how we consult in
terms of process now actually if you
with document it just says that and
I think that part of what you're getting
we're getting we're getting into getting
into realms of it is the council's
consultation process what this is about
this is a statement creatine involvement
which we have to do is part them our
legislation which sets out ways we will
consult and the way we can soul if you
would look at that page six point two
seven sets everything that we discussed
mailing lists website libraries adverts
notices groups posters leaflets social
media invades that is the way that we're
going to be engaging with the residents
that is what we have to do the way of
which we then look at that engagement
that's that that is dealt with by the
council's consultation and arrangement
what this has to set out in law is how
we engage the processes we use for
engagement that is what it has to set
out we're getting I think at the moment
we are can we r getting involved with
actually the the process of that we then
have to take this document and align
this document alongside the council's
adopted consultation arrangements in
terms of how we take this document
forward because what we have to set out
is here is actually what we will do in
terms of consultation and that is set
out there very clearly it then goes on
to how you submit your comments it then
goes on to consultation feedback now
what iswhat I think that we could put in
here to meet the concerns of of
counselor as the Mason right beginning
of this is that after power of F 2.4 we
could put in there could be
another paragraph inserted at paragraph
2.4 which then deals with and I think
your folks was but was actually very
very very valid about the re-engagement
now at paragraph two bottle we can put
another paragraph that actually makes
your your suggestion that that we doing
the consultation process so during your
six weeks your nine weeks or 12 weeks
there is regular reviews of the
responses and at that time we then
review the process we've done already
because we might decide that that will
take them you know state for an
application and we can piss for
everything but verification we might
decide that we just do we have to do as
a matter of fact a site notice and we
have to notify adoring neighbors now we
might find that actually we think it's
kind of the application and actually had
no responses to it now we might blow it
then to do a different something
different because sometimes you get no
responses you think oh my god why is no
one responded so additional paragraph is
but sets in there that says that we will
review the consultation process during
the period of consultation to ensure
that there is that we though it is the
correct of them that we use the correct
type of consultation now that I think
I've it goes right back to our
discussions might actually be a a way of
dealing with your point right beginning
is the fact that we we put paragraph 2.5
expands the process that says actually
if we just put the review mechanism in
channel episodes and Chris example I say
from / from obviously past we've got a
look at the future and from past I've
spoken to many people it's almost like
the cancer means a fait accompli they're
going to do what they're going to do and
that's it and this reason more we know
you know they they look at they may look
at the pavements they may not look for
the papers but they considered to be
fatal completely they know what they do
it and that's just the sort of the
things that they've got it sitting there
with leaflets maybe going to use water
public awareness well what leaflets
where are they you know no that's well
this is you see what we're doing this
visit we've been going did you what we
want to do yeah yeah that's not
something we've got that damn damn here
and this is something that we really
couldn't could you okay you said you
have good job yeah and if you record
them and i'll make that reputation at
the very beginning I I repeated it yeah
so have it have it been picked up by
Christine I'm really please don't i'd be
really pleased if you know this the
subcommittee would agree with that in
terms of
Chris's car last comment about we didn't
leaflet this engagement was because it
was on the old engagement so and the old
iam didn't include this is the piano and
I need to recognize that because it
sounded fair to do so but in doing so I
know we straight on to you know the
parish engagements and we've discussed
you know how views on that I got the
vidya prescient that all that was going
to inform the issues and options was
that engagement process if when if I'm
now advised that it's going to be how
much how much wider engagement using all
of this consultative process before we
get to a point where we can do an issues
and options that is meaningful to the
people who receive it then I'm happier
provided as you said there is a further
meeting we hope this committee before
we've proved propre progressed through
the process of getting to an issues and
options and how we do that by engagement
because I'm concerned I was very
concerned having read the second paper
and talk to some residents that all of a
sudden in October they were all that you
know we were going to have a lesser
important issues and options document
then I was expecting I mean a checkup I
have no problem Sonya mug whatever if we
feel that the way it is to have a
routine monthly meeting and we have a
routine
I think we really good actually I think
I think I think I'm very so if we mess
misled you in that because I think that
only I've taken a quite a few hints of
lot of a local authorities in pain you
know they're preparing agent options and
calls really good ones look at actually
because call love because collins
unitary authority now and they've got
something like forty eight parishes so
as unity authority with thought so it's
a it's a it's a busy unit authority but
it's because it's so big the parishes
have almost become like independent
little little district authorities on
their own now and they looked at some
significant engage with the parishes to
actually allow them to do a local time
and it has had some batteries from from
the parishes upwards so if you look a
lot the work call of doing that's where
we've taken a lot of the lot of this
work promise from that from their
engagement and its own part I have to
any part because we've got it we're
building an evidence base a moment which
is costing money and that will attach
use what's in it you know it's it's you
are you add it all together this isn't
options is massive input all the
information that we've got that throws
out these these options in terms of you
know I've suggested because there's no
policy writing is an option so it's just
basically a very very quite dirty
document in terms of small thing or
anything else that actually size to set
a theme for the counts are going forward
and I would say no good chance for us
because chance is actually really good
in terms of what it does and it actually
has created as you can see by fourteen
thousand responses a headache for that
policy team in terms of actually now
dealing with we've taken that forward in
terms of how they have to do all the
responses and how they think December
they're all information so i think that
is the i think that the the crater that
document has to be not passively looked
at very carefully because we want to
make sure we get the right engagement as
early as late as possible so we
hopefully can get down to the plan
making process and actually
we reduce the number of responses as you
go down the pros which is what it should
do we really should buy the local plan
stage are your submissions document you
should be having very few challenges yes
yes if you did the start the beginning
right and just save this work we're not
being negative here that we've all been
through some very nice at times over the
last few years and we don't want to go
through them again that's the route that
this it's not looking didn't believe
obstructive awkward away about but we
don't want to go through some of the
sagas what we've seen them here over the
last year or so and this is what we're
trying to smooth out or eliminate or do
when approached you want to use to
pretty clear and all of these issues
before we get it up to the crunch if
we're happy to put in the extra 2.5 to
cover this issue to have a monthly
meeting to review where we go then then
so be happy beautiful I'm stove and this
just wonder where we can put in this
issue of um so it's not hard it is a car
I know it hard to reach rly society it
is that whole unless we put some in that
paragraph that deals with a review that
deal with the real mechanism an
assessment of the responses to date so
then that allows us so the responses are
all swag towards men in their fifties
and we actually whenever you actually
start looking at why every thought
anybody else so we put in a paragraph
that says that will do with a V
mechanism to assess the paper the
progress and the consultation to look at
number of issues and that can be you
know around people and areas cuz
obviously forget all the responses from
Rayleigh and then from note and no for
no one else and we've got a panic the
fact that it hasn't anyone got the
document and that again it's quite see
sometimes that things go wrong and
documents he don't people only only one
area find out something and the rest of
so we'll put something in that paragraph
around it's not review the mechanism to
look at
responders and airy basin so it's more
about if I can sort of people in terms
of that is a hard to reach is a not a
nice label insert another when you think
of young moms with children how do we
reach them when they've got very busy
lives maybe through the Children's
Centres even you know it's that sort yet
up there and how do you engage with
those people whose lives are so complex
disrupted in whatever way that they
don't actually have time to even think
of going online and checking remember
there's a consultation that they might
want to results then gave of the schools
we found when I was a new one was
actually quite good because you engage
with it with it so we said we used to
always pick gear six because you six are
quite quite good because you've got a
choir they're quite eloquent to that
point in me and we did a thing about
where's my home and it's also
interesting because you drop truth which
these doing actually fit for autumn you
draw out you get them to draw a plan
showing where their home is and then you
show and they say where's my school was
my shop where's you know and then you
put an overlay an actual plan that shows
where ever they actually it's quite
interesting so they can start
understanding about planning and about
you know why things need to be near or
non-linear where's my name is first
start was musing tube stations have a
lots of stuff quite interesting but what
we did as well is crater leaflet that
that goes in all the children's school
bags that goes home with all the
children in the whole school so actually
I know it's just one school so we picked
on any repeats on three or four schools
but actually it's quite interesting that
you put that leaf in their bag and
parents normally do deserve two bags and
they and in that leaflet we support
quite surprised that actually but if it
does get home and actually it is that
whole thing about how did you get things
homeland and actually so in some
respects you do pick up on the mothers
that aren't at work and
so those so is that is actually quite
those sort of the engagement of quite
interesting and they just tend to
promote you know discussions around the
school gate around during you have zoom
the school and everything like that is
anything is then followed on from there
so that is a good way of doing that can
we say them I mean we frequent although
this scenario for the rest of the day
can we setup agree though the idea that
we've got the we will elaborate on
paragraph 2.5 that will have a monthly
meeting yep and down a few ideas like
this you can't bring them forward to us
and we can kick them around all yes no
whatever as as we progress so as we go
through the summer before we get to the
end of autumn time you you should dig no
she there with all the parishes nor
we've got all these other bits and
pieces on coming and we are aware of
what's going on and then it began to us
to feed it back to air groups or our
councils or whatever whatever we do you
see if you've got any if you are
affiliated with any and we did a quickly
joined a line dancing and maybe put some
line dancing group as well which is
really good actually well they were just
a group of people that got together from
all over whatever new room and we
actually went to one of their sessions
reacted bit line dancing and then we had
a bit of you know session at the end
around you know what you know what what
they wanted so actually the engagements
gotcha quite good because Winston what
they were doing so it's actually that so
if you know of a group that might be
interested in that it knows more of a
district-wide group and an elderly group
they it was that was quite it was quite
inspiring actually because you start to
look at that that their needs and
actually their needs on a different
anyone else's needs but it's just
listening to what they have to say was
actually really it was really
interesting so it's actually those those
sessions that you don't omit the basis
if you know there's something going on
and say look this is going to go on then
go down and
they all like young people does it send
them down it and you know and with with
with some missing points to talk about
and they're quite good for that sort of
engagement that is just the point where
more members would be perfect to engage
yeah in the process because they
validate the process and there no moping
feel so David that's that's like dancing
doughboys we tighten you doing stories
partly shapes yeah yeah yeah halogen
doctor that we can we agree that we and
we kick this around you long enough the
we thing that we put something else in
place can we move on then to our posting
to suggest that we go through from page
six point one three which is the issues
raised and we may click again any
leagues if you afraid I mean I've read
through them i guess you go read through
them as well it as we go through based
if there's anything that you
specifically wish to elaborate on or
comments on with regards to these
offices comments when we elaborate on a
warm clarification on we can go down
that road as well okay so we start on
page 6 13 6.13 is there any any issues
on that pace that you don't agree with
the ball wish to have comment on or
clarify or anything I'd say challenges
that you know Vicki on 6.3 13 and other
pages it clearly reflects the
frustration of the previous period so
I've got little more to say except to
record that yeah I think that I think
Jonah
I don't think you're the people in that
has that few that's why we're trying to
go through the very process to make sure
that we don't go down this road again I
mean I know I saw one in their
willingness to engage in Kasota why is
this any different so very serious all
cynicism and I know Morgan and an arm
and I'm justified I don't have any from
my reading of all these I could most of
the opsys comments you know work
reasonable i don't think there were 12
areas where I don't see what else they
would say other than what we say to be
honest Chris I would just might say that
consultation Easton is the best thing is
we've talked you to the public and once
upon a time the council used to send
their representatives then walk cancers
to maintain speed the puppy of an
evening month 11 Michael whatever once a
month or whatever that was I can't
remember any maybe so d really Toby
right yeah they were brilliant then they
work you took everything that they said
and you took it away and the way you
went I mean I was at the meetings I was
one of the public I told me yeah baby
okay so I need to he took you like the
other take you on your shoulder oh yeah
oh yeah it sort of listen and take it as
it comes and this is where I people
you know the item and we need to
re-establish that we can panic I don't
disagree with you Chris and why don't I
have you to do it but well a lot of us
they're mean if we go into other areas
now but it's not just a question of
whether it be ironing or concentrating
on this whatever it's the fact that you
know counselor is admissible and the
residents know that they are and where
they are and that they are approachable
and and that I mean joon-young you've
made trip down here we are we are
visible in air force and you could find
about all sorts of things I don't know
why that has broken down in some areas
or it doesn't happen but you know like
it fine falls on a sunday afternoon the
same as everybody else does about this
that the other Christmas Day which this
day yes whatever Vivian or is it sorry
Joe sorry don't know I didn't realize it
was a 24-70 okay because I maybe God if
you get annoyed to rely wat now the
police no no it's ' stolen and just know
you know it is different here but I need
a couple yeah have we any more coming to
mind other that are becoming item six
other than to recommend on page six
point to them the recommendations on
this committee with the amendments that
we've already agreed that's at the pros
modifications always set out yes a table
3 plus a review of an additional
paragraph two point from
in appointed and I don't know whether
we're putting their arm under review by
creating a that's what we need so for
full count so we can basis a that it's
been agreed following a modification
center and additional paragraph required
and then so that's that document done
and then we can then say is that also
recommended that in line with but that
was different matter in line with the
the local crown process we're looking at
a monthly meeting to discuss the
progress of the local plan okay
paragraph on it how was that going to be
you know do you want always thinkin
right it she can serve it later yeah
sorry Lisa go yes i see do we do before
once you yeah we will do it'll be done
by to be done by friday yeah the love of
my friday passing it around and we'll
give you until next wednesday to respond
we take no response when you okay yeah
active if anybody does have any comments
you could just notify everybody well
what do you view so because we my other
sharing or not sort of the more or less
the one case where a bottom always
appropriate that's right
can I how's Jerry phone I can second
only because I'm not all the Corinthian
such can I sit at other meetings that
you have to reverse it and I meetings if
you Chris wants to make you a permanent
sup that's up to Chris yeah that pervy
sage don't get here yeah we want
interested in it and year and I've got
is less motivated like that's how you
feel you want to progress and at on
quizzes in the ground in this mode
problems of cartography right moving on
to that's a lot easy to talk with the
two I'm till the general problems of the
econ today we are moving on sir lighting
from number seven which it is you're
planning a policy projected work program
like it a brilliant I've seen it have a
granny comments to my further that
haven't now been subsequently covered
I do want to impale you I looked at
appendix I in particular because I was
very interested in the engagement which
of course we discussed in terms of
detail but this is further detail with
you I have in my group we have a board
member in hockley is particularly keen
to see hampi parish council participate
in this community engagement and as i
understand it from an email arrecife
movie attended ugly parish council
meeting and they agreed so I'm really
hopeful to find that it where it says
summer 2016 all other parish workshops
then we see hopefully in their engaged
because you know I promised him that I
would make sure that in this process
that it does does happen if hopefully
Parish Council want to do it
notwithstanding my own narrow the use of
the narrowness then I don't see how
as far as I'm aware there is no problem
with this is you this is your intention
just haven't got the engagement of
everyone and then we've had and hold
would have come back to us and they
really keep their very clean yeah so I
can call it work the recently on
apparently trying to get the best out of
the 106 agreement for them into some
some youth facilities at benefit for
them and some of the other stuff and
actually the I've something to get you
some of the Gilders up there as well so
I think hot and hold would you think it
is they've they see the fact that this
has got to be a positive engagement and
my point with hold which is about that
you know they must make sure they get as
many people as they're as possible from
a wide range of thinner of sources and
I'm we also came to get businesses there
and we have businesses that contingent
and we had we had the aunt Vivian
Canadian as well which is really good
because that's what about the whole idea
is to try and promote actually you know
the the community not just being
additional house in so on so yeah
basically will and they're just going to
get the table go out to over the next
few weeks and trying everybody signed up
ok what sort of numbers coming handle
chair because that's a question that has
been debated by this council Reeves
actually
me I said I don't know I've asked the
question because he wants to leaflet a
lot of his ward now I'm really
supportive of that as you know from what
I said so he's following him in a good
footsteps I think I'm it up but I'm what
I'm worried about tis he knows he did he
leaflets everyone and says is these
workshops and you get best part of 500
people wanting to attend that's the
issue yeah you need a cross-section of
people which we know which we had a
Rockford we had a canoodle I think sort
of between 25 and 50 you can do it
because it is very much workshop based
very much better in small tables very
much actually been out it's very much
about looking at looking at plans
looking at maps of your area and
actually a lot of is just you know
writing on me we've got some amazing
stuff that came home of one guy can even
knew more about the area than we ever
knew in terms of rights away things is
quite enlightening hisses was but you
know is actually just a really extreme
engagement real discussions and actually
what is quite surprising is the pit is
that I like those commute events because
people livin don't need only talk to
each other at you and chat in as well so
it's not just about the council coming
out of it in terms of put the plan
making the community is something out of
it because people that don't normally
talk to they're actually quite chatty
and actually quite knows engagement to
there as well so i would say up to 50 is
what we I think once you get past that
we haven't got the support staff in
terms of our staff to manage any more
than that because it would get I think
you would get too big and then you lose
that you lose that that workshop side of
things is there another system that's
helpful yeah question again further
question from Council years old or I
will represent you in our group and
other groups you know as best I can
and his question is also will that be
included in that discussion because it
seems to hold and I know he's very keen
to get a view from residents as to how
that can be revised copy area yeah are
very very big on that communities agenda
I mean that that's part of that of that
of that of that area anyway so it has to
be part of the process and actually this
the time which we can do one of two
things we can pull all up all those
documents into the new local plan so
they all stand as one big document or
they can stand alone so the options are
that this process the the discussion can
be and one of the items that you can put
for hockley is and otherwise we've got
at the rock and really would actually be
where does the action plans sit so
perhaps part of that I've service even
fully integrate they should be educated
on my experience yes not you know i
dunno often very well so we can have a
not an item on the agenda for that
session to do with actually the action
of the action plan and then actually and
there's part of the the walk-around hot
clean perhaps that can be part the area
which we actually choose is to actually
go and have a look at that area itself
as well because it only areas are quite
big and the and the wall crowns do
actually work probably but what you can
do is you've got a number like 50 you
can perhaps do two or three groups so
you can have one lot goes off with the
action planning area while not goes off
and looks at the new recent development
areas which is quite interesting to look
at those and what goes off and look
something else and you come back and
then those three groups that operate as
that you know you get a lot of props
that discussion between to what the
three groups have seen but the back yeah
that's fine
that's very good until I seem to be
asking the next question obviously the
hobby town center plan if you like it
it's also a great interest not just to
hotly but also the whole world yeah
because you know I've become involved in
it because I've got so many residents
who make comments on it so when we do
the hopeful one we should equally be
asking issues verbal yes yeah on the hop
I tried to make this it is quite the
yeah it is the parent like you is easy
cuz it's it's it's on its own but a lot
of the when you start looking at the
main collimation areas within this
street they all d crossover so
cross-boundary shoes and around about is
you know is key in the town center isn't
it and you know encouraging how do you
resolve that I not on the pub and
resolve that but that's my opinion I
know it is how you thought it's question
how you resolve that isn't it you know
is all those questions about what you do
too because that roundabout is much prob
with anything else isn't it because that
just not at the district and well the
one project can do a lot of things and
if it knocks down the pub I don't know
how old is it well can I make a comment
go on and make the push again thank you
no it's just the observation with regard
to the actual groupings with both
community and Rochford and how it worked
and it was cross border we got people
from not just kinnunen game and the same
would Rochford we had not just people
from Rockford but adjoining areas it did
seem to be you know the people who did
attend within the workshop and and the
whole idea is to keep it manageable
within let's say between 25 and 50
those people who did attend would have
been how can I put it leaders within
their various areas here so they would
then fleet back to their groups to let
them know so it would be a spread out
another web going out but what the mouth
so it just introduces people to what's
going on but it was that
interconnectivity and it was the bit it
was the interaction this was the most
important thing that you know trying to
build on with the development of these
meetings within the parishes okay it was
the parish that facilitated but if the
driving force is coming from us
basically you know to get as many people
included within it and it worked very
very well these initial get-togethers
seem to be very positive the feedback is
incredible the views that people have
and you know views and views by
protected views especially in kinnunen
which areas that you know they wanted
protected that was very very important
going into rockford we were just looking
it was basically looking at traffic flow
it was looking at so many different
things that affect the mechanism of life
within Rochford and within the square
all these things came came into it and
this was local knowledge this was really
really important so you know people who
knew their area the interconnectivity
held each area impacts on the other so
you're quite right John with regard to
hopefully properly definitely impinges
on hook well and what goes on and so
there has to be the interconnectivity
that's all
all our district members allowed to
attend yes is your course it's not that
this note there's no hole instead of
course I just want actually put one in
one society like two min so much slap go
away no come on get able to look after
day you might have to do some similar
you might be able to drool and Aurora
you have to since they do actually how
many members do want to ten it might be
interested especially on this committee
that you do a system for society because
only it that is actually quite useful
when that's due to know which is just
looking at the gathers you know it is
quite just ending and you do you do you
know what I think you know the ones with
them so far they have been quite quite
enlightening can I be really mean and
ask being questioned that nobody really
wants to answer and that's how will this
work with rayleigh parish maybe more
raelia vania we've been approached by
when you're ready and they've asked us
and what size room for the late about
this music questions that would help
bring the room and
you know we go back and said no no it's
a collaboration approach so I think my
question really is are we then really
just talking about the town center if
we're talking about a walkabout in
raiding well we have this Australian the
other option we've got the raise that
you could take say we can say that you
can start at three points in the parish
we have 33 people to restart so we might
have one that sort of more towards the
north end of rayleigh so we actually
walk around in that area you have a walk
around the town centre and you have a
walk around maybe some part of the town
at the parish boundary and then you
actually then all meet back at at up a
spot phone for your discussions
afterwards we do to our wand around in
different places and then you will come
together at a fixed point because that
then you've got you've got three three
groups doing different things and then
you come back to a central point that's
we have discussed that run ourselves
because otherwise you are for us to get
out to places you're going to be looking
an orphan all day in terms bird's nest
between you we offer 33 meet places have
a wand around we've got some ski areas
to look at or a lot of that was driven
by it wasn't different buyers we used to
look we're doin of them and so who's
making that decision
maybe that's another question for hear
of it I think that would be Marie we do
that that's engagement if you're looking
to Natalie and two down and two zaliens
they look okay fine how we're going to
manage it how we're going to deal with
it where do we start who wants to be
there that's fine nice again it's not
we're not delivering this we're not was
trying to step back and say actually
this isn't for us to deliver this is
that just isn't own counsel if you
discuss in this meeting coming well yeah
is it I think we need to engage here we
go again consult with our own tail yeah
so you might notice it said it was going
to be discussed on the twentieth of june
and i didn't get to that meeting what's
your guys know there are no fee bucket
it's fine i know if you were to change
this is completely we're not gonna
there's no other gonna say oh well
that's that's you come to us and say
that we think the best way to run it is
that we start for four different points
in within the parish boundaries and we
will be more person here one person
there one person there will have four
key members here can you put some a
member of staff with that will all come
back to x2 wherever is at twelve more
coffee and biscuits and an hour and a
half's especially after that and that's
then you're mr. session isn't it and
then because that you know that's what
we want to look out come in and that's
the same with you know if hockey hall of
honor and that's similar one where we
meet out and then we come into a central
place not one with that at all so if you
want to talk to the camp
encounter about that and come back to
the same well actually we consider this
is the best way is that we meet you in
these three spots and then we the parish
hall is all of the web halls available
from this time we all go their then
there's a very nice little piece on sore
from statistics of that which is we
actually really is quite is quite
enlightening actually statistics of you
of your the relevant parishes looking at
ages and all that sort of stuff it's
quite quite interesting school rolls and
have the scores and affecting things and
then we have some one hour and a half
discussion about sort of you know
looking forward what are the key issues
in those relevant areas do we won't grow
where's the growth of the go business
growth town centre enlargement highway
improvements infrastructure for
infrastructure improvements having to
pay for it what we need to do is it's
part of our mystery look we're talking
ready to count about infrastructure so
there's all the discussions going on at
the moment so you know it's very key
that we took start up putting all
together so it screws oh I know is that
we've got summer for another parish
workshops obviously hullbridge and
Rory's are going to come in on the edge
and Brady I don't know how that one's
going to work out with that gets for us
to work there we're just going to side
with is there some which has got to be
worked out as to when you opening up for
Brady perish if he likes or think I'd
want any of us
r us to decide a we will not yet come
over you I think what you're going to go
to your parents or with that I useffin
are you saying I think how did the two
councils get together to make grants to
get because it's really what you're yes
it normally do that but that that can be
arranged however is not big deal when we
were in the summer i think there's no
reason why the carpets something like
yourself is good for him okay I'm so
let's hang on yeah it's not fun push
this in Irish come here recommending the
door sir recommendation for one night
and seven yep yep I think Christine this
is your last week a tepid or friday yeah
so here into on behalf of this committee
I think on the server thank you very
much for your contributions I guess been
eye opening for a lot of us and your
experience has been invaluable in in all
sorts of areas big [ __ ] to fill so
you're going yeah I bring my black then
more than a hot Saturday
thank you very much Christina's been a
real pleasure working with you and I've
certainly learned a lot and I'm sure the
other guys for sure thank you very get
Tiger telephone number chesty there's
nothing else else for the meeting that
summer's gone already